here is the new US Army
AD stand
up there okay I've seen a lot of
straight looking white guys seen more
straight looking white guys than I've
seen in any army ad in recent memory and
then they wow and there's it's not
social activism they're just jumping out
a helicopters with
parachutes the greatest victories are
never achieved alone Be you can be even
a return to the old US Army motto when I
was a kid be all that you can be I felt
better about our prospects for peace
back when the US Army ads did not focus
on men fighting and preparing to kill
our enemies back when the US Army ads
focused on women bragging about their
lesbian mothers I suppose one of them is
probably the mother and going to Pride
parades and festivals and rallies
growing up